Speaker 1: at this point.
Fox News is a tool for Russian propaganda.
Now, I'm not asserting any kind of collusion.
I'm not saying Russian officials are feeding
talking points to Fox News.
I'm not saying any of that.
But what I am saying is Fox News's coverage
of the Russian invasion of Ukraine is really
useful from the standpoint of propaganda value
to Russian state television.
I've previously told you about this memo.
This was about from about a month ago, exactly
a month ago.
In fact, a Kremlin memo was sent to Russian
media, saying it's essential to feature Tucker
Carlson's commentaries into in terms of their
coverage of the Russian invasion of Ukraine
and particularly early on.
Tucker's coverage was very, very pleasant
for Russian propaganda purposes, so we already
talked about that previously, that's that
leaked memo.
We also know that Russian state television
has referred to former Democratic Congresswoman
Tulsi Gabbard as our friend on the basis of
her interviews with.
Yes.
Also with Tucker Carlson.
And we now also have another example of this
where in Russian media has aired a clip from
Fox about so-called growing concern over far
left lunacy in schools, which includes trans
rights.
Clay Travis was the guest, the right wing
media personality, as he's often referred
to, and that was also useful.
Remember that in the midst of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine, Russian state media continues
to be obsessed with a very similar kind of
anti woke so called and he woke ideology that
is very much in line with Vladimir Putin's
cultural preferences, cultural positions.
And there's a lot of great material from Fox
News when it comes to that.
So it's always really important when we look
at these things to understand that the term
useful idiot is often really useful.
And I know it sounds like a pejorative, but
it's a it's a term.
A useful idiot is someone who is being used
by others for their own gain without even
realizing it.
So very often, you know, back in the Trump
Russia investigation days, there were some,
I guess, who were setting their standard,
as is.
They're going to be video of Trump colluding
with Vladimir Putin and Putin telling Trump
what he needs them to do and whatever.
And as I and many others said, that's never
going to happen.
That's not how these things work.
We're not talking about that.
What we're talking about is more of a useful
idiot relationship where Trump wouldn't even
realize that he is furthering the goals of
Russia, which is making the U.S. look like
a joke, which it was when Trump was president,
making our democracy appear unstable by fomenting
the idea that what we did, did the winner
really win this type of thing?
And similarly, it's not that Russia's giving
Tucker Carlson talking points.
It's sort of similar to I hate to say this
because I had friends who worked for our television,
but a lot of our people used to call when
Archie was still on the air in the U.S., they
would say.
They hired me.
They never told me what I had to say.
They never edited my scripts.
They never.
I do whatever I want here.
You were hired either because what you are
already planning to say is useful to Russian
state media or because your presence by virtue
of your identity is useful even if you're
not toeing the party line.
It's sort of, like you could say, when Shep
Smith was on Fox News and we would say he's
his lone voice of reason.
And it was the the whole point was it allowed
Fox to say, we're fair and balanced.
We have all sorts of different views here.
Nobody was telling Shep what to say, but he
was on for one hour and then the rest, and
then they could say, Well, you know, we're
fair and balanced.
We we have all sorts of views.
So understand when we say useful idiot, it's
the term idiot is pejorative, but useful idiot
in total describes someone who is unknowingly
being used by others to further their agenda.
And that's exactly what we're seeing on Fox
News next Tuesday.
6:00 PM Eastern April 19th will be doing the
next David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall.
I hope you'll join me.
Everybody is welcome to call in and it'll
be streaming live on our second YouTube channel.
That's YouTube.com slash Pacman live.
We'll take a very quick break and be right
back.
The David Pakman Show is a community, grassroots
supported program, were supported by our audience,
and the best way is through our membership
program at Join Packman dot com, you can sign
up and get yourself a membership.
You can also gift a membership.
We have nearly 700 people who have asked for
free memberships, people who want one but
can't afford one.
You can ask for a free membership at David
Pakman dot com slash free membership.
You can give a membership by signing up at
Join Packman dot com and checking the box
that says this is a gift.
When you go through the signup process, of
course, all of our members get The Daily Bonus
Show, an extra show that we do every day for
our subscribers